an illegal alien just followed a u.s
senator democrat kirsten cinema into a
public bathroom to harass her about an
upcoming vote and to demand amnesty and
a pathway to citizenship
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us we
need seven million citizenship for seven
million we need the
benefit right now
my name is blanca i was brought here to
the united states when i was three years
old
and in 2010 my grandparents both got
deported because of sc 1070
and i'm here because i definitely
believe that we need this pathway to
citizenship my grandfather passed away
two weeks ago and i was not able to go
to mexico and visit him because there is
no pathway to citizenship and if we have
the opportunity to pass it right now
then we need to do it because there's
millions of undocumented people just
like me who share the same story or even
worse things that happened to them
because of sb 1070 and because of
anti-immigrant legislation
in a serious country
this woman would be deported before she
could say ola muchacho
but because we are not a serious country
at the moment she won't be in fact she's
being applauded by a lot of the american
left she is not worried
at all
she is so unconcerned about being held
to account for this serious crime that
she is currently committing that she is
flaunting it right in front of one of
the nation's supposedly most powerful
lawmakers and it isn't just illegal
aliens it's the media it's the
entrenched interests it's the exalted dr
fauci flaunting their expanding and
illegitimate power
and laughing because there's nothing you
can do about it i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from old school man
old school gets the
top comment like
two out of every five days that is very
impressive uh he writes quote for the
first time in history the
ineffectiveness of a medical treatment
is being blamed on people who haven't
even taken it
that's true basically every single
problem is being blamed on just about
one group of people and uh
all of the other people are getting away
with whatever they want to get away with
it's enough to keep you up at night
though when i want to sleep easy at
night you know what i do
i put my head on my pillow you know how
much i love my pillow one because it's a
patriotic company we all like that but
two even if they were run by chinese
communists i'd still buy from them
that is because their their product is
just so good it's the best one out there
well my pillow wants to give back to our
listeners you can get great discounts on
all of my pillow products if you go to
mypillow.com right now click on the
radio listeners specials
get deep discounts on my pillow mattress
toppers towels so much more for example
my pillow is offering a buy one get one
free offer on the giza sheets they are
top quality sheets you are going to love
them all my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty it could be a 50-year
warranty you're not going to want to
return them they're that good
you're not going to want to
send them back your you might want to
buy multiple sets like i have done
they're just a top quality product go to
mypillow.com click on the radio listener
specials for the buy one get one free
offer on the giza sheets use promo code
dailywire at checkout or call 800 651
1148 you'll also get deep discounts on
all those other my pillow products the
pillow the towel sets the
slippers the mattress topper that's
mypillow.com enter daily wire or call
800-651-1148 tell them dailywire sent
you 800-651-1148
the deals won't last forever so call now
this woman
this illegal alien lady
who doesn't sound like a three-year-old
i don't know about you she says i was
brought here when i was three and she's
still got quite a bit of an accent so
she hasn't learned a ton of english
perhaps maybe she's learning english but
she hasn't assimilated quite so much
during all that time since she's been
three years old she is now complaining
that she's not allowed to come and go as
she pl she's in this country illegally
she's not allowed to come and go as she
pleases because if she leaves people
might realize at the border that she's a
foreign national and has no right to be
in this country and so they might not
let her back in but she wants to stay in
so she doesn't get to go on vacation she
doesn't get to leave the country she
doesn't get to go see her family outside
of the country right your family's
outside of the country because that's
where that's where you guys are citizens
and then some people broke the law and
came here illegally and now you're
complaining about this
further further do you hear what she
says at the beginning
she and her friends say we put you in
office we got you elected and we're
going to get you kicked out of office
admitting that illegal aliens are
affecting our elections
she's saying i'm an illegal alien i put
you into office
why is that in part it's because some
illegal aliens are voting we know that
for sure we know that they're affecting
the election in other ways they're going
door-to-door they're canvassing they're
interfering in the election process i
don't want to hear a word about how
someone's colluding with the russians
which isn't even happening or ukrainian
interference or russian interference or
whatever
when we have
millions and millions and millions of
foreign nationals
influencing our elections right here in
the united states what happened to our
democracy isn't the bedrock principle of
our democracy that the citizens get to
conduct their own elections
no not not in this country
in this country this woman is so
feels so easy that she's going to go
walk up to a top
lawmaker in the united states and say ha
ha i'm breaking the law hahaha hey make
it easier to break the law it shows you
also how they've shifted the overton
window here on the left initially
what people would call for in this case
is deport deport her and deport all of
the other people who are breaking the
law by being in this country then the
argument moved to look let them stay
don't deport all of them deport the
really bad ones but let the other ones
stay and they'll keep their heads down
and it's fine and because we acknowledge
birthright citizenship in this country
and we are fairly confident in that for
the past at least recent decades then
that's fine
now we've moved it all the way over to
give them amnesty or they'll harass
senators in the bathroom does it seem
like the right thing to do compassionate
just i don't think so
it's not just the illegal aliens i mean
this woman should be deported
you know by the end of this program but
it's not just the illegal aliens and
it's not just the people encouraging
illegal immigration it's the whole
liberal apparatus
this kind of hubris you're seeing
probably most clearly with dr fauci okay
dr fauci has gotten everything wrong
what he hasn't gotten wrong he's just
lied about and dr fauci
went on hugh hewitt's radio program so
hugh hewitt a conservative but he's
still sort of center-right conservative
lawyer and radio host
gets fouchy to come on this show
and hugh hewitt you got to give him
credit he reads him the riot act
the controversy over the um
the use or non-use of ivermectin and
there was no study yet completed dr
collins told me it's not done yet the
the
no discussion of of natural immunity
which exists and not to be out there
the discussion of herd immunity which is
swish switched back and forth the mass
discussion at the beginning don't wear
masks the noble lie and then wear masks
now equity issues in the fda panel
scientific discussion
i've lost confidence in the cdc and the
fda and i actually believe a lot of
americans a significant part of america
now have lost confidence in you dr fauci
is there a point where you will say
i do more harm than good because people
don't listen to me anymore and step
aside
no
absolutely unequivocally no no
no you sheep i mean he's going down the
list i actually truncated the the hugh
hewitt club he goes on and on about all
of the flubs that fauci has made and
that just goes nope there is nothing
that you can accuse me of doing that
would get me to step down
they asked joe biden this some months
ago is there any is there anything
that dr fauci could do that would lead
to you're firing him he says no
no there's not
he's the most powerful politician in
washington he's the top paid employee of
the federal government dr fauci
and that's that he is in power he can
lie to you he can mislead you he can
deceive you he can just plain get stuff
wrong
he will not give up his power and what
are you going to do about it there's
nothing there's nothing you can do about
it
joe biden doesn't want to fire him but
frankly he probably couldn't even if he
did
want to fire him that is how entrenched
this guy is and fauci is using that
power it's not like he just has the
power and he's just going to sit on it
kind of like republicans when
republicans get elected to office they
say okay we've got all this power now
and we're not going to use it
fauci is using it he
used it to lock us all down to shutter a
bunch of businesses to shutter a bunch
of churches and to cancel holidays
you'll remember last year he said don't
go to thanksgiving don't go to christmas
don't go to this don't go to that well
now we are what a year well over a year
and a half later
and dr fauci has asked
again
this is
pulling into the back part of 2021
the anchor says dr fauci please
can we please dr fauci can we just have
christmas this year
here's dr fauci's answer
we can gather for christmas or it's just
too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we've just got a concentrating
on continuing to get those numbers down
and not try to jump ahead by weeks or
months and say what we're going to do at
a particular time it's just too soon to
tell if you can have christmas
like the grinch he is the grinch he is
now
obviously i haven't paid attention to
what this guy i mean i've paid attention
and that i covered on the show but i
haven't listened to this guy's advice at
all period not once from the very
beginning of the epidemic and i feel
much better for it and i think my life
is greatly improved compared to those of
my friends because i have tuned out dr
fauci
i will probably be dinged
for
spreading misinformation or something or
something like that because i say don't
listen to dr fauci but i want to be very
clear here i am not saying don't listen
to dr fauci because he doesn't know
about the science i think his record on
the science speaks for itself and it's
not particularly flattering
but i'm making a political point here
this twerp
has no credibility i don't think he has
all that much legitimate authority and
it is beyond
his job description
to
cancel christmas he doesn't have that
right and if you go along with that if
you are a la are allowing some twerp
bureaucrat to cancel one of the most
important feast days of the year for
your for your
family for your culture and for your god
then your priorities are way out of
order
you should just
tune this guy out in general as far as
i'm concerned but specifically when it
comes to christmas
i guarantee you dr fauci will not be
coming out and saying hey blm rider the
next time that there's some probably
hoax but even if it's a legitimate event
that causes some at least performance of
grievance i guarantee you dr fauci will
not be coming out and saying no blm
rallies stay home no he won't say that
at all the public health establishment
didn't say that in 2020. the liturgy of
the looting is permitted to occur the
blm riots are permitted to occur just
not christmas
and that's not
hypocrisy it's it is a double standard
it's a hierarchy it's the culture being
led by these freaks telling you the dr
fouches of the world saying it's very
important to go loot the nike store
that's that we have to permit but
celebrating christmas with your family
no no can do sorry follow the science
if you want to protect life not just
your life not just our way of life but
the the many many babies per year who
are killed
senselessly needlessly through abortion
i recommend you check out 40 days for
life the abortion topic seems to be on
everybody's mind these days because
we've got major supreme court cases on
the move the big women's march quote
unquote was just a pro-abortion march
great new pro-life laws in texas and
florida working their way through the
legislature
if you are struggling on what to say or
how to say it when abortion is the topic
of conversation you need to check out a
new book what to say when the complete
new guide to discussing abortion since
its release it has already been a number
one amazon new release and number two
amazon bestseller it's already on its
second printing the book is from 40 days
for life it's the largest grassroots
pro-life organization in the world
they've held peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities in 1 000 cities in
64 countries they've helped convert the
hearts of 221 abortion workers they know
their stuff
this is an invaluable tool it's a timely
tool get it right now what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion how to change minds and convert
hearts in a brave new world go to amazon
or get it directly from 40 days for life
at
40daysforlife.com go get this book do
not be stumped when this topic comes up
there's another major racial incident
you know look it's a racist country
it's an evil racist country and slavery
is the original sin and it's we've never
gotten over it there's no redemption
in this view of american history and of
the world and so because it's such a
terrible racist evil country
there's a new new report out that the ku
klux klan is on the loose in georgia
terrifying a black neighborhood
going
mailbox to mailbox leaving threats to
burn down these people's homes
and to kill them and oh it's a hoax
perpetrated by a black woman
oops
wow cause i i thought i sure thought
because you know i listened to the
mainstream media and so i just assumed
that the ku klux klan in 2021 is running
roughshod over all of america
terrorizing black people but it turns
out it's just another hoax just like all
of the other ones
a 30 year old woman teresa lucas
who lives in the atlanta suburb of
douglasville has just been caught and
charged with eight counts of making
terroristic threats after leaving
violent hateful notes
in which she claimed to be a white
member of the ku klux klan
the letter uses the n word it talks
about the kkk about lynching people
killing kids killing families and
setting a house on fire according to one
concerned father rightly concerned who
received one of these notes the notes
threatened to burn their houses down and
kill them and said that they don't
belong in the neighborhood
but it was all fake and it's a black
woman doing this herself
there are two kinds of people who are in
the ku klux klan in 2021
hoax artists like this woman
and fbi agents
that's the membership okay at the annual
ku klux klan
conference the retreat i don't know
where they hold the return i guess they
probably hold it in this neighborhood in
georgia
you have
a bunch of hoax artists
who are trying to gin up grievance for
their own political ends and a bunch of
federal agents and i think that's it and
maybe there's like one guy there's like
jimbo who never got the message that the
ku klux klan hasn't been a thing in
decades other that that's it that's the
whole thing so why why is this woman
writing all these hateful vicious things
about her own race about her own
neighbors why is she doing that
this is a pain this is a painful thing
isn't it
no it's not it's pleasurable this is
pleasurable this is like the leather and
the whips and the chains and you know
this is a sado-masochistic society
it is pleasurable for people in our
perverse culture to be able to claim
pain and victimhood it gives them
pleasure and it gives them social
currency and it gives them political
advantage which is why people do it they
do it as bad everyone does it if you if
you've got some weird sex thing you
claim that as victimhood if you can in
any way claim to be a racial minority
that will give you victimhood if you can
claim to be a a woman
not just if you are a woman but if you
can claim to be a woman that will give
you some kind of
social currency
women are considered to be a minority
they're the only majority of the
population it gets to be claimed as a
minority
that is what carries
in this culture and it's it's a it's a
religious view right because you know
what you're going to hear from people
when when you point out okay you know
all these hoaxes i
chronicle a ton of them in my book
speechless just right down the list
specifically on campus all of these
racial hoaxes
almost every time you see a big high
profile case of a noose or
an n-word or whatever or a swastika
almost always it's a hoax okay
why
why because there's no
actual ku klux klan out there there's no
actual skinheads marching through the
street there's none of it's real
and yet the religious premise here is
that racism and white supremacy pervades
america and so when that isn't the case
you just have to make it up you have to
it's a noble lie you heard hugh hewitt
referring to the noble live dr fauci the
noble live dr fauci it you know in his
in his mind was
i think that the masks will stop the
spread of the virus but i i don't want
people to go buy up all the masks and
for there to be a shortage so i'm going
to say that the masks don't work that
was his noble lie at the beginning of
the epidemic
here too the noble lie is the
the ku klux klan writing all these
letters because even if it's false
it gets to a greater truth now it
doesn't it just gets to the kooky
bizarre racial and religious premises of
the left but for the left white
supremacy explains everything you heard
this from ayanna presley
she is one of the minor members of the
the squad
you know the john and paul of the squad
are aoc and ilhan omar they're kind of
the leading act and then probably iona
presley
i guess you would say rashida talib is
is george harrison she's a little more
out there and then ayanna presley she's
she's the ringo okay but those are the
four of them so ayanna presley just
comes out and she is attacking pro-life
laws and she's very upset that babies
are going to survive in texas and she
says that pro-life laws i kid you not
pro-life laws
are rooted in and an expression of
white supremacy
the year 2021 has been the most
devastating for abortion rights in
american history in the midst of an
ongoing global pandemic that robbed us
of more than six hundred and ninety
thousand lives and disproportionately
impacted our most vulnerable and black
and brown communities anti-abortion
legislators in 47 states focused on
legislating hurt and harm to push this
critical health care out of reach
these misguided bans will not actually
prevent all abortions they simply put
safe and necessary abortion care out of
reach for our most vulnerable
specifically our lowest income sisters
our queer trans and non-binary siblings
black latinx aapi immigrants disabled
and indigenous indigenous folks and none
of this is happenstance it is precise
like the roots of the anti-abortion
movement these bans are rooted in
patriarchy and white supremacy they
perpetuate cycles of poverty and
economic inequality and exacerbate many
of our starkest health disparities
enough
so virtually everything she said there
is not true but i want to focus for a
second on what she says the roots of the
anti-abortion movement
are in
patriarchy and white supremacy
the opposite is true the pro-abortion
movement is rooted in
white supremacy margaret sanger the
founder of planned parenthood the
eugenics movement more broadly was aimed
at reducing the number of black people
in america and killing the black babies
that are conceived through abortion and
this is not some wacky conspiracy theory
you can read it in her writings they're
finally now at planned parenthood
starting to take down margaret sanger's
picture and name from buildings because
it's a little politically awkward that
you've got this anti-black eugenicist as
the face of the organization but that is
the effect of it black people are killed
disproportionately through abortion in
new york city today it is more danger
the most dangerous place in new york
city for a black person is in his
mother's womb the majority of black
babies conceived in new york are killed
through abortion
this i don't think the the mythical
white supremacist out there who's
running rampant in some neighborhood in
georgia
even though he appears to be a 30 year
old black woman you know the the white
supremacists
would probably be perfectly fine with
that wouldn't they with with black
babies being killed because then there
are fewer black babies and they have
less share of the population and right
it would seem to me that the people who
don't want to kill all those black
babies they're the ones who have far
greater care for black people
but let's go even further than that
in africa
abortion barely exists in africa itself
this is according to the gupmaker
institute which is
a pro-abortion think tank 93 of women of
reproductive age in africa live in
countries with restrictive abortion laws
okay even in countries that do allow
abortion it's it's
very limited they're very few women who
can actually get it
10 out of 54 countries in africa ban
abortion outright all but four countries
place very heavy restrictions on it
abortion is the colonialism abortion is
the white supremacy abortion is the the
awful export that we are now trying to
force on africa how are you going to
tell me that pro-life laws are white
supremacy when practically the entire
continent of africa itself has pro-life
laws now you might tell me well that's
just a product of colonialism that's a
fa that's embedded white supremacy
well who came up with the pro-abortion
movement first well abortion i guess and
eugenics is the kind of natural pagan
state of mankind it was practiced in
ancient sparta it's practiced in a lot
of pagan civilizations
but do you see how this is unfalsifiable
any evil
that you want to point to
in the world can be blamed on white
supremacy well what what if
what if it's only black people doing it
and not white people well that that's
because of their ingrained white
supremacy there's no
way
out of this sort of thing
i also i also like here that ayanna
presley is admitting that abortion is in
no small part about sacrificing babies
at the altar of money she's saying it's
really hard to get ahead economically if
you have a baby and that's why we need
to let women kill their babies you're
saying we need to have
women and black women specifically kill
their babies so that they can make a
little bit more money
that that's the way you're going to
frame your argument doesn't sound
particularly moral to me sounds like the
strange ravings of some kook
religion
if you want to cherish your memories
people perhaps who have gone people you
know pets places special memories i
strongly recommend you check out paint
your life i absolutely love paint your
life this is the gift for a loved one
for anything for a birthday for an
anniversary for christmas for mother's
day for just for yourself i've been
putting up art on the walls you know
since i got my nice tennessee house and
my favorite pieces are from paint your
life okay if you want to give that
meaningful gift go to paintyourlife.com
get a professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo or multiple
photos at an incredible you'll be
shocked to hear about it price
this
painting i know people don't really
believe it it's a real painting with
real brushes and real paint
by a real world-class artist who will
work with you until every detail is
perfect got a user friendly platform
makes it easy to order custom-made
hand-painted portraits in less than five
minutes and you'll get your portrait in
as little as two weeks and the quality
is unbelievable at paintyourlife.com
there is no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed right now is a limited time
offer get 20 off your painting 20 off
and free shipping to get this special
text the word michael mich ael to 64 000
text michael to 64 thousand mish ael to
64 000. text it paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
term supply available at paint your life
dot com slash terms text michael msh ael
to 64 000. go check out paint your life
today also
you got to tune in to ben shapiro show
is a new civil war coming he's going to
answer that question he'll at least ask
that question go check it out we'll be
right back with a lot more
during the trump administration there
was an expression that became one of the
slogans on the left and it's that the
cruelty is the point
and they were referring specifically to
trump's border policies which weren't
materially all that different from
obama's or even clinton's border
policies and they're certainly not
different than biden's border policies
which are pretty
pretty brutal right now
you know kids in cages that sort of
thing he said the cruelty is the point
okay
the only difference was that trump was
trying in some way to slow the number of
foreign nationals pouring into the
country and joe biden's really not not
doing that at all but you're still
getting the kids in cages you're still
getting all these kind of cruel actions
though i don't think that was the case
with uh trump i think with trump the
point was to enforce the law and get
people to to follow the law
but the head of planned parenthood this
woman alexis johnson has just come out
and she at the at the women there was
another women's march no one really paid
any attention to it and the women's
march is now basically just a
pro-abortion march so
she comes out and she
embraces
an aversion of this slogan but in a
positive way as she sees it she says
that the the entire point of the women's
march and the pro-abortion movement and
the left broadly
is to turn pain
into purpose
look y'all
this moment is dark
it is dark but that is why we are here
movements exist because of darkness
and it is our job to imagine the light
even when we can't see it
it is our job
it is our job to turn pain into purpose
to turn pain into promise and to turn
pain into power
turn pain into purpose turn pain into
promise turn pain into power that is
what they're doing and for people who
are confused
about the border policies for people who
are confused about the immigration
policies and then the illegal aliens
going in and harassing female senators
in the bathroom
and going out in the street and burning
things down and looting and rioting and
the left apparently being perfectly okay
with this the left in some cases even
encouraging it kamala harris sitting
vice president who who is bailing out
the rioters that i if you're confused if
you're confused as to why
a black woman
would pretend to be a white man in the
ku klux klan to terrorize her neighbors
it's because you do not understand the
principle that this
head of planned parenthood just espoused
pain into purpose
pain into promise
pain into power
and if the pain does not exist if the
country's basically just fine and people
aren't being oppressed and having their
rights taken away and you know in great
mortal fear all the time and if they're
not in that moment you're going to have
to create the pain
and you're going to make the pain and
then you're going to exploit the pain
for purpose for promise and to seize
power that's what's going to happen
and a lot of what we've seen
on immigration certainly on the racial
stuff but notably on the coronavirus
lockdowns
has to do with that
the coronavirus for the vast vast vast
majority of people is a cough
we all know people who have had many of
us have had coronavirus already and it
was to varying degrees
unpleasant to you didn't even know you
had it okay and for some people in
specific risk groups it was really
really bad
but for the vast majority of people it
was totally fine certainly would not
seem to warrant locking down the entire
world for 15 days that turned into
coming up on two years
so why did they do it
pain
do you get it pain into purpose pain
into promise pain into power and they've
taken a lot of power and they're not
going to be giving that power back any
time
soon this is part of a broader left
strategy i'll give you an example of
this from georgia there's a state
representative there donna
a democrat
and she is a state rep in georgia she
told the atlanta journal constitution
that she really doesn't look like the
idea of there being a statue to clarence
thomas they were thinking of knocking
down a bunch of confederate statues in
georgia and then what are you going to
replace them with well someone suggests
how could you replace it with
with clarence thomas
right he's black so he's not an evil
white man he's a black guy even though
the left says that the very black
clarence thomas is a white guy but you
know white guys they're the most evil
people in the history of the world so
okay it's a black guy and he's a very
accomplished jurist and a very
accomplished man and a wonderful
judge on the supreme court so good let's
put a statue up to him
certainly that'd be better than
jefferson davis or something right and
this woman says no
she says i'd rather them keep a
confederate monument
than have a statue of clarence thomas
that's how much i don't like the idea
and i don't think that she's in the
minority of democrats
on this topic
i think this shows you something that a
lot of squish republicans didn't
understand
when the left started going out going
after robert e lee for instance
a lot of the squish republicans said oh
who cares
who cares it's just robert e lee he's a
traitor
he's uh i'm glad he's a democrat
that'll show them yeah they don't even
know those idiots they don't even
realize they're taking down the statue
of a democrat
yeah tear down that statue yeah i i like
that they're tearing that down actually
yeah this is a total win for me even
though it's only democrats pushing for
it and that we're giving them exactly
what they want yeah this is a huge win
but it's not it's not first of all
that's that wasn't the attack that
abraham lincoln i think would have taken
right malice toward none charity for all
bring the country together the south is
part of the country we're now going to
have a country again after the civil war
but furthermore
tearing down those statues never had
anything to do with robert e lee
never had anything to do with stonewall
jackson never had anything to do with
andrew jackson if you want to go back a
little earlier never had anything to do
with thomas jefferson earlier than that
or george washington or anyone else that
they're tearing down or christopher
columbus for that matter
it had everything to do with you
okay when
the libs tear down statues of old dead
white guys they are tearing down statues
of you not even just you white guys out
there every single person alive today
who is in any way a conservative they
are tearing down the statues of you
and they would rather keep up a statue
of jefferson davis than have a statue of
you even if you're a black guy even if
you're a modern person even if you
didn't own slaves or whatever
it was that the act of tearing down
historical figures is not about
primarily canceling christopher columbus
it's about canceling
half of the country
and keeping you out of political power
and keeping you out of influence and
making sure that you have absolutely no
say in how you how we run this country
together
in how your communities are run or
frankly even in how you run your lives
which is why you you no longer even have
the right to celebrate christmas
according to some people in the
government you're seeing this
to a slightly greater extent even in
australia right now
there's a video going around viral of
some cop
you know australia's under very serious
covid lockdowns a cop shows up wearing
one of these dinky little masks and she
she walks up to a person's private
residence
and she begins to explain why it's very
very wrong and awful and illegal that
this person even suggested that maybe
they might go out and protest the
lockdowns
is there a reason why you're recording
me today yes for my protection
do you think i'm going to assault you or
something no um
so
i don't understand why you're here
and i haven't even spoken to you and you
think i'm going to
do something to you well we have seen a
lot of police violence in recent times
towards the public and there is a
growing
there is a growing mistrust i as you can
understand um
yeah not here do anything like that all
right let's go we're here to have a chat
to you because we have instructions that
um you've been posting some things on
social media
and
that you
got a protest protest on tuesday
um there's no protest on tuesday
there isn't okay that's fine but what
i'm here is to remind you to ensure that
you need to stay at home in relation to
covert
and um stay at home orders and if there
is or is not a protest on tuesday
regardless you still can't leave and go
to a protest of any sort i understand
sunday tuesday wednesday thursday
anything like that
i just want to to to talk to you about
something yeah
yeah i don't know what accent i'm doing
yeah yeah i just want to talk to you
about something yeah it's like a mixture
of east london and south african yeah
yeah where would you i saw what you
posted on there on the twitter
and you said you might protest the
government
no no you cannot do that i was spying on
your social media and i saw you
protested the government and you cannot
do this wrong and you see us how
concerned this cop is no look it's just
for you
yeah you just you can't do that yeah
all right when i cut it out with this
accent i sound like some just east
london soccer hooligan
this sort of thing is it is coming here
already it already kind of is here in
the united states so it's not as quite
as widespread as it is in australia
what's most interesting about this clip
to me
is that you've got an ostensibly
conservative woman
using some of the same rhetoric here
about cops as you might hear from blm
there have been a lot of incidents with
the cops the cops are encroaching on our
rights there have been some violent
incidents like when the cops start
spraying you with rubber bullets and so
i'm filming you for my protection
you hear that same thing about from blm
here in the united states that the cops
are out you know racists and they're all
going to just try to hunt down as
innocent black guys
now
i point this out because the in the
institutions in the west broadly are
crumbling
people don't have faith in them anymore
hugh hewitt said that at the top i don't
have faith in the cdc i don't have faith
in the fda when neither side has faith
in our elections in 2016 all the dems
said that hillary actually won in 2020
all the republicans said that trump
actually won
blm says that the cops are not to be
trusted and are overstepping their
bounds the conservatives now are saying
the very same thing now
so this pose is a big problem for the
establishment but i i want to be careful
here i'm not saying that both sides are
making equally valid claims
when blm says that there's an epidemic
of cops going out racist cops trying to
kill innocent black people it's just not
true it just isn't happening it's not
backed up by any evidence or any
statistics whatsoever actually very very
very very few
black men innocent black men are killed
by the cops every year infinitesimally
few and even unarmed black men which
doesn't mean unjust shootings are very
very low numbers okay so
that those claims are false whereas
the claims that cops are shutting down
businesses that claims the cops are
people keeping people locked in the
claims the cops are showing up to
churches and shutting them down that is
happening and that did happen for a lot
of 2020 and it's still happening and
it's happening notably in australia okay
so those are different things
the claims that trump cheated in 2016
because he colluded with the russians or
whatever there was a multi-million
dollar investigation of this it just
wasn't true it's completely false
okay the claims that there were
shenanigans in the 2020 election are
obviously true forget even for a second
the audits which have raised i've talked
about it on the show have raised some
serious concerns about the integrity of
the election but even just the the way
that all the election integrity measures
were taken away
so many of them before before 2020 that
in
pennsylvania the way the the election
was conducted was in violation of the
state constitution
the the the use of ubiquitous
unsolicited widespread mail-in ballots
the use of ballot drop boxes
all of these raise questions and so i
don't i'm not saying well both sides are
making these claims saying one side is
making much more serious and justifiable
claims than the other one but neither
side has
trust in the institutions anymore which
is really bad news
for
the ruling
class look what they're doing now
through their proxy of social media you
know big tech is technical i guess in
some ways it's technically the private
sector even though google and the
government are very hard to separate and
lots of google was funded by the
government and they work in cahoots with
one another so it's a little bit blurry
public and private there but in any case
the ruling
establishment uses big tech as its
enforcement arm
twitter is now
not just censoring news reports that are
damaging to democrats twitter is now not
just censoring conservatives they don't
like up to and including the sitting
president of the united states donald
trump in january
twitter is censoring obituaries
there's an obituary going around over
the weekend of a woman jesse berg wilson
the obituary went up and and
referred to this woman who did not want
to get the coveted vaccine she did get
the coveted vaccine she was finally
pressured to buy her job by her
community and then she died and she died
of
according to the obituary
covid19 vaccine-induced thrombotic
thrombocytopenia v-i-t-t surrounded by
her family she was 37-year years young
she was a mother and had no underlying
health conditions this according to
the obituary so the obituary makes it
very clear they blame this on the
vaccine
we know the fda and the cdc have
admitted that the vaccines have caused
blood clots and similar conditions
specifically in younger women and have
led to death in some cases so none of
this is some kooky unsubstantiated
misinformation the cdc has admitted as
much
and yet this obituary that was going
around over the weekend
stopped going around for a while because
twitter censored it you could not reply
to the tweet
you could not like the tweet which would
share it to some degree and you could
not retweet it without adding a comment
and then when you looked at the obituary
it said this obituary is misleading
imagine what the family thinks
seeing that the obituary is misleading
i don't know what happened to this woman
i
have no reason to not believe the
account because even the cdc has
admitted that similar incidents have
taken place that's why they paused the
johnson johnson vaccine because the
johnson johnson vaccine caused
conditions just like this one in women
just like this one okay so i have no
reason not to believe it but here's the
one thing i do know whether it's true or
not
if
the article were an obituary for someone
who said
this person really didn't want the
vaccine and then this person died of
covid and her her dying words were i
wish i took the covet vaccine you can be
damn sure it wouldn't be censored it
would be promoted it would be trending
news it would be pushed by the
propaganda wing of the ruling class
but because the ruling class hasn't a
leg to stand on on so many of their
claims and no one trusts them even the
people who are inclined to trust them
don't
they've got a clamp down sensor sensor
sensor even censoring some poor young
mother's obituary young mother was
bullied into taking the vaccine when she
felt that that she
did not need to and that she was in
overall good health and she was willing
to take the risk of contracting the
virus rather than
taking the experimental vaccine
the
ruling establishment
is really really turning up the dial on
the propaganda to a way that would be
really funny if it weren't so sad
you may have noticed at some
public events recently there has been an
uncouth chant that has this is sporting
events
concerts
and what people are chanting is
f joe biden and they chant this a lot at
all these sorts of events and it seems
to happen out of nowhere and you've been
hearing it for weeks now so
nbc shows up nbc sports shows up to a
nascar race all right nascar
probably not filled with the highest
percentage of biden supporters of any
event in the country
and they're interviewing one of the
drivers and in the background you can
hear
this chant cropping up as it has in a
lot of places and the reporter refuses
to ignore the chant but also refuses to
acknowledge the chant instead the
reporter chooses to rewrite the chant
thank you to all of our partners
oh my god it was such an unbelievable
moment
brandon you also told me
you can hear the chance from the
crowd
let's go brandon you told me you were
gonna kind of hang back those first two
stages and just watch and learn what you
learned that helped you there in those
closing laps oh my god it was uh
learning how
line didn't uh
stay to one everything shifted top to
bottom
do you think they were saying
let's go brandon
i look i don't have the best hearing
okay but i didn't hear let's
le i mean because i agree i believe that
brandon should go go himself i agree
i i
whatever they were chanting i think i
agree with that so if it's let's go
brandon sure brandon go go yourself go
go yourself brandon but i don't think
that's exactly what they were saying and
what's so offensive about it
is that
i i don't think this woman's hearing is
clogged any more than ours is she heard
what they said and she rewrote it
and she's looking at all of you you
can't see her on camera but she is
effectively looking at all of you and
saying hey that thing you just heard you
didn't really hear it
that thing that you're hearing right now
behind me that undeniable loud thing
that a crowd of people is screaming yeah
they're not really doing that
no no you know what they're saying
they're saying let's go brandon
yeah that's right that's the ticket
let's go brandon
if
the press are lying to you about this
what else are they lying to you about
this is like that thing drew clavin
points this out a lot you open up the
newspaper and you say oh syria okay and
this is what's happening in syria okay
that's fine i believe that and oh hey um
taxes yeah okay this is what's happening
in taxes okay i believe that and oh hey
the yankees and wait a second that's not
happening with the yankees no it's not
whatever this reporter's writing isn't
true and i know that because i follow
the yankees
okay well time to oh healthcare policy
okay that's what's going on healthcare
so you know on the one thing you know
about you know the press is lying but
then you go ahead and you believe them
on all the other topics that you don't
know anything about why there's no
reason to believe they're any more
trustworthy there than they are
here if they're going to lie to you
about what someone is chanting directly
behind their heads
that you can see you can see their
mouths moving for goodness sakes
they're going to lie to you about
anything that serves their political
advantage
so what do you what do we do about this
there's a county in north carolina who's
taking matters into their own hands
county and north carolina
is insisting that its local school board
institute a policy that would discipline
or fire teachers if they assert that the
founding fathers were no good terrible
awful people and if they make statements
undermining the constitution and if they
assert that racism is this perpetual
problem in america that's never going to
get any better
they would be fined or possibly fired
awesome oh man that's great there are
going to be three reactions here there's
going to be the left reaction which is
this is terrible and their heads are
going to explode and they're going to
say not only should they not be fired
for this but they should be required to
teach them america's evil and the
constitution's terrible right that's the
left-wing reaction then there's the
squish libertarian reaction which is
well actually you know this threat is
academic freedom and the teachers should
be allowed to teach whatever they want
about the founding fathers and actually
the eighth grade classroom is a free
marketplace of ideas and whatever right
so that's the squish version and then
there's the conservative answer which is
oh yeah teachers shouldn't teach false
things if they teach bad false things
they should lose their jobs because
they're not fulfilling the basic job
requirement of being a teacher that is
providing students with an edifying
liberal education
liberal meaning making sense of your
freedom learning true things mastering
your deep worst impulses and being ready
to be a free citizen
so
i guess the devil's in the details here
but the johnson county board of
commissioners is going to withhold
almost 8 million bucks until the policy
is accepted by the school board
north carolina schools are denying that
they're teaching critical race theory
and all this stuff but they are they're
just just calling it a different name so
what's the actual policy the actual
policy says no student or staff member
shall be subjected to the notion that
racism is a permanent component of
american life good glad you're right
absolutely if a teacher violates that
should be fired number two all people
deserve full credit and recognition for
their struggles and accomplishments
throughout united states history and if
you don't give people the credit that
they deserve and if you only talk about
the negative things and you don't talk
about any of the positive things you're
gonna lose your job great love that
awesome the united states foundational
documents shall not be undermined of
course this is the basic this is the
basic idea of public education is you've
got to
give you've got to educate people to be
citizens to keep the country going
that's the whole point of it so yeah duh
obviously they should be fired for that
no employee of johnson johnston county
schools will make any attempt to
discredit the efforts made by all people
using foundational documents for reform
good no fictional accounts or narrative
shall be used to invalidate actual
objective historical events good yes
obviously the left is going to spin this
and they're going to say you want these
teachers to teach
fabul fables and and sort of nonsense
and fairy tales about a founding note
they're saying no fictional accounts no
only real history good all people who
contributed to american society will be
recognized and presented as reformists
innovators and heroes to our culture
good fine but that's the most
controversial one but yeah that's the
idea people have contributed in a way to
american culture that we now defend as
part and parcel of citizenship and
the way that we look on ourselves based
on real historical fact they will be
presented in that light yet duh makes
sense and failure to comply will result
in disciplinary action up to and
including dismissal that's right baby
that's right that's what we've got to do
time to say no i know that republicans
only conservatives only ever like say
yes yes we'll be inclusive yes we'll
bring everybody in you'll never face any
consequences you'll never be deported
we're for open everything we just it's
got to be legal and it's got to be in a
certain way but we want everybody to you
can harass senators in the bathroom but
you got to do it legally okay right and
we know we want to open up the
curriculum and we want everyone to
pursue their own individual autonomy
however they want no
no
no liberty requires limits and
that entails saying no
and that entails a little bit of cancel
culture which exists everywhere in every
single society and instead of only
canceling the good stuff instead of only
canceling the stuff along left-wing
ideological lines instead of only
canceling george washington
i think we got to start cancelling the
libs i'm michael nolan's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show